Let's get back to calculating precision recalls and
F scores for the classifiers that we've built.
If you look at this line of code, the classification report class from
psychic learn gives us a very nice summary of all these metrics.
Let's run this piece of code.
For each of the classifiers.
You will get values for precision, recall, F1-score, and support.
The support column, contains the total number of actual positives and
negatives in the test set.
The next line of code gives you a count of the false and
true instances in each of the classifiers.
We can also calculate the F1-score, F2-score, and F0.5 score.
Run the last block of code now.
Now you have different values of the F1, F2 and F0.5 scores.
Using these scores you can make a decision of which classifier will
work best for your needs.
We have now come to the end of our map.
We have now worked through several examples of the iteration between
questioning, modeling and the validation process of model building.
Towards the end we changed the model and change our definition of the classes.
We introduced to you different performance metrics like precision, recall,
and F score.
We showed you also how to choose a model based on these performance metrics.
Hopefully you followed along and were inspired by all the lessons in this class
to continue learning about the various methods of model building and validation.
Hope you enjoyed learning from us as much as we enjoyed making this class.
Good luck and good bye.